i'm shannon bream i'm tom shaloo I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Friday February 14th 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony as Mike Bloomberg rises in the
national polls the Democrat is facing
more criticism from the President and
Eric Trump piles on he's spending
millions millions of dollars every day
he's clearly trying to buy an election
but where is he I mean he's not out
there he's not being seen he's not
having rally he knows that no one will
show up for his rallies and I just don't
think he has the charisma to get across
the finish line
I'm Kris foster Fox News Sunday host
Chris Wallace is on talked about the
2020 presidential race and president
Trump hosts impeachment just imagine if
it were Barack Obama doing it to protect
one of his cronies that you'd they'd be
going out of their minds and I'm Brian
Kilmeade
I've got the final word on the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
just to contests into the 2020 race for
the White House one candidate stands out
with the most momentum at stake in our
present battle is the survival actually
of our nation President Trump won big in
Iowa getting 97 percent of the vote in
the Republican caucuses prompting one of
his two challengers joe walsh to drop
out then the president won New Hampshire
easily so he's confident he'll again be
the GOP nominee facing one of the
Democrats my only problem is I'm trying
to figure out who is their weakest
candidate I think they're all weak that
was at a rally Monday night in
Manchester we have more in this arena
and outside of this arena then all of
the other candidates meaning the
Democrats put together and multiplied in
the primary the next day the president
got 85% of the vote of New Hampshire
Republicans bill well just 9% adding to
the Trump momentum out of Iowa I mean
the enthusiasm there Dave was amazing
his son Eric Trump is executive vice
president of the Trump Organization and
I wouldn't smoke at one caucus sites and
again my father was running pretty much
unopposed and you know we had hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of people show
up at every caucus site wearing you know
Trump tear you know bring their kids
bring their family I walked into my room
they're chanting USA USA USA I mean that
the level of spirit in the state again
on a night that no one had to come out
because he was gonna win the state you
know we were respective and he's again
running really unopposed was was
unbelievable and I think that kind of
speaks the sentiment of the country you
know then obviously we had you know the
impeachment sham finished up Nancy is
kind of a gift that keeps on giving I
mean the amount of money that we raised
we had 1.4 million new donors in the
last quarter of last year people who had
never donated to a presidential campaign
before many of them had never voted that
were donating to my father's campaign
because of helps they were then we had
an absolutely amazing State of the Union
you know which was which was incredible
to say the least and the Democrats are
coming off a horrible a couple weeks
Nancy Pelosi ripping up the State of the
Union was just discussed
it was a disgusting act it was a
disgusting gesture now that it's after
impeachment they are still leading
investigations and one of the things
there's a story you've probably seen in
the Washington Post on Thursday that the
House Oversight Committee is asking the
Secret Service for information based on
Washington Post reporting that the
Secret Service is paid to the Trump
companies nearly a half million dollars
you're charging him hundreds of dollars
a night for rooms for a cottage in
Bedminster New Jersey at the trump
National Golf Club what's your response
you know it's disgusting I see that
story and it's disgusting and you know I
worked I worked on that story quite a
bit and and and and those writers are
just you know David Ferran Holte is the
you know hit person for the Washington
Post who comes after my father every
single day and it's it's disgusting you
know they talk about you know the US
government paying $600 for a room at
mar-a-lago and it's not $600 for a room
it's $600 for many rooms and you legally
by law you have to charge them the
federal government something otherwise
you get into all sorts of gift laws and
you know we charge the United States
government cost so we could go out and
we could sell a room for $1,500 a night
there's very limited gorillas moralizer
the hottest place in the world we charge
them cost-effectively helps keep them
cost and they go out and they you know
they say we charge $650 for a room which
was many rooms and then they go off and
you know they say well in bed Minister
they take you know they take one room
and they pay X amount per month and when
in reality it's many many rooms and as
many other ancillary things and again we
charge cost we lose a fortune you know
having the United States government at
our properties in s find my father from
day one always said you know this is
this is the greatest calling you know
and we're willing to do that and if they
stayed anywhere else they'd be charged
10x what we charge because again you
know we make zero profit on anything
government related but you'll have the
crooks over at the you know the
Washington Post they'll come out with
stories which is absolutely disgusting
you know talking about us quote unquote
you know profiting
government they write in the story these
payments show he has an unprecedented
and largely hidden business relationship
with his own government it's amazing the
amount of money that we lose off of
these days in fact I joke all the time
that I would like nothing more than to
never have another you know person from
the government stay at one of our
properties because it displaces you know
it true paying guests you know people
who are using restaurants and using the
facilities and using everything else but
it's it's disgusting what they do I'm
not really disgusting what they do will
you then since you would say you have
all the information will you just hand
it over to the House Oversight Committee
and say this is the this is the truth
here it is the post is wrong they're not
asking it of us are asking the Unites
States government not they're not asking
this of Trump organization they're
asking the United States government and
and and no I'm not about that you know
hand over what the Secret Service
protocols is and how they protect the
president the United States know that
some think I wouldn't do what there is a
big controversy about Roger stone a
longtime Trump associate convicted in
the Russia probe for prosecutors
withdrew from the case when the
Department of Justice intervened calling
for a lighter sentencing next week after
the president said that a nine year
prison term recommendation was
ridiculous
the DOJ says it acted on its own but
Democrats are calling for attorney
general bill bar to resign Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer what is
more stinking than the most powerful
person in the country literally changing
the rules to benefit a crony guilty of
breaking the law what does Eric Trump
say in this country I think people have
seen it there's there's in equal justice
and that is you know evidently clear you
know two days ago you had a wild lunatic
you know hop in a pickup truck and try
and crash through voter registration
site you know Florida you probably saw
the story absolutely I'm try to kill
conservatives who had Trump sign who
were registering you know people to vote
you know these are young you know
Volunteers of a campaign who are out
there doing a job this guy hops in the
car and tries to kill them gets arrested
you you see things in MO way other than
Fox News and I give you guys a lot of
credit of them and then you guys no one
even brings up the story ABC doesn't
talk about the story NBC doesn't talk
about the story CBS doesn't talk about
not a single news organization though if
if the roles were flipped and and and
that was a trump supporter who did that
to a you know somebody in a make America
great had and they did that to Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or one of
these other candidates
you better believe it's the only thing
anyway would be talking about for weeks
and weeks and weeks and it's absolutely
disgusting I guarantee you no one would
be talking about this there would be no
sentence for Roger stone if he wasn't a
Republican and you know vice versa a
look look at the sentence that this kid
will likely get it probably pales in
comparison to the sentence that they
want to give Roger stone and I think
what's become very evident to Americans
in this country is that there's unequal
justice if you're a Republican you know
you will get throwing you know down the
to for doing absolutely anything yet you
know if you're Loretta Lynch if you're
Hillary Clinton who destroys thirty
three thousand you know emails if you're
you know James Comey and all the fraud
that were perpetrated there if you're
other other people in that circle if you
have a D in front of your name you can
get away with absolute murder you
mentioned some of the Democratic
candidates I want to go through some of
them with you Bernie Sanders is that a
candidate that you hope that your father
has against November and November that
he has a the Sanders wins the nomination
do you hope that absolutely Dave but you
know I mean truthfully I kind of hope he
runs the any of these people and I you
know he will one of them right so I mean
I'd probably answer yes to to to any of
the candidates you threw their name in
there but there's an embracing who want
eighty-five percent taxes in this
country um you'd be encrypted every
business in this nation there's no
question about it he wants to strip a
health care from 180 million Americans
who have private health care plans that
they really like and you've talked a lot
about how bad the health care systems
are in this country the one thing that
works well is private health care wants
to take away a hundred and eighty
million private health care plans that's
that's people that's families that's
that's plans that children Iran that's
Union plans in this country he wants to
strip them you want to hand that over to
the US government I mean the Democrats
you know a week ago and I wouldn't count
a hundred seventy thousand votes yet
they want to be responsible for running
health care for
entire nation and stripping it away from
no companies and people who do health
care really really well and private
plans which people like and work and
again it's probably the only thing in
our health care system you know that
that works the Buddha judge if he were
the nominee would he is a civil or
moderate would that worry you know I
don't listen I just don't think he has a
chance for a whole lot of reasons for a
whole lot of reasons you know first of
all he wasn't a good mayor in in South
Bend there's tremendous racial divide
necessary that was caused by a lot of
those various things he did he's really
got no experience I just don't I don't
think he can do it I just I I look I
think we'd be thrilled to go against
Pete I just don't think he can do it I
then asked Eric Trump about Mike
Bloomberg who's been rising in the polls
in the Democratic race for president now
in double digits he's run a ton of ads
on TV and one shows a lot of
unflattering pictures of the presidents
playing golf
people have said when you were mayor the
city gave Trump a contract to operate a
golf course yes that's true but he was
the only bidder and running a golf
course is the only job that I would hire
him for on Thursday president Trump
again derided Bloomberg as mini Mike in
a tweet calling him a five foot four
massive dead energy Oh Bloomberg tweeted
back a short time later we know many of
the same people in New York behind your
back they laugh at you and call you a
carnival barking clown they know you
inherited a fortune and squandered it
with stupid deals and incompetence and
then Bloomberg added I have the record
and the resources to defeat you and I
will on Thursday the former New York
City Mayor campaigned in North Carolina
one of the Super Tuesday States in March
the one thing you can't buy in the world
is its personality and you know I know I
know Bloomberg you know we know him
obviously from being being from New York
and you know if you look at all the
people who have done well in
presidential you know elections over the
years look at the Clinton Raynham in
Brooklyn has a certain charisma has a
certain personality that people were
drawn to Barack Obama has a certain
greysun personality that people were
drawn to Ronald Reagan has a you know
personality and kind of charisma brand
that people
are you know are drawn to were drawn to
still are drawn to my father clearly had
the same thing I mean he could bring you
know 30 40 50 thousand people into a
rally and you know people would be
chanting USA I mean there's just
tremendous enthusiasm for him I think
you see that every day you saw that with
the Iowa turnout you saw that in New
Hampshire
I mean his numbers in New Hampshire were
the highest in the history of that
primary by a lot I see that every single
time I go to a rally or every single
time I post something about my father on
Twitter or every time I walk down the
street the one thing you can't buy is
its personality and enthusiasm and love
there's something that these candidates
had so we'll point : the ride it's it's
it's something and I can tell you we
know Bloomberg well enough and he
certainly doesn't have that and I don't
think Mike Bloomberg can get the Bernie
voters because they detest everything
that he stands for which is you know
kind of all we know a wealthy
capitalists etc he's certainly not gonna
get anybody on the right you know he's
gonna grab him he wants to get his guns
I think the racial comments where you
know make more black people should be
being arrested than white people as
Bloomberg liked to say you know I think
that's going to disqualify him in in
more ways than one so those statements
and you know it's not just the statement
but the way he said the statement were
pretty pretty disgusting but your father
was a supporter of the stop and frisk
program wasn't he yeah but I think it's
different first of all he ran away from
stopping first my father's supporter of
keeping the law enforcement officer safe
in this country and allowing them to do
their jobs
I mean he's spending millions and
millions of dollars every day he's
clearly trying to buy an election but
where is he I mean he's not out there
he's nothing to seeing he's not having
rallies he knows that no one will show
up for his rallies and I just don't
think he has a charisma to get across
the finish line
Eric Trump as always thank you very much
for joining us yes thank you
[Music]
this is brian kilmeade with your fox
news commentary coming up Bernie Sanders
now leads in most polls after Iowa and
New Hampshire we are going to unite
together and defeat the most dangerous
president in the modern history of this
country Jill Biden and Elizabeth Warren
are looking to bounce back it ain't over
man we're just getting started is best
position to beat Donald Trump in
November because we can unite our party
there's pee poo to judge men Amy
Klobuchar both strong in New Hampshire a
fresh outlook is what makes new
beginnings possible it is how we build a
new majority I cannot wait to win the
nomination then there's Mike Bloomberg
who hasn't been on a ballot yet and
still averages third in national polls
[Music]
so there may be a front-runner and
Sanders but no one close to looking like
the Surefire nominee the race is shaping
up a little bit although it's remarkably
muddled still Chris Wallace is the host
of Fox News Sunday clearly Bernie
Sanders seems to be winning in the the
left the liberal lane Elizabeth Warren
has performed very badly for somebody
who had invested so much time so much
money so much effort in Iowa and New
Hampshire I'm not quite sure how she how
she survives she has basically taken
down all of her money for ads in South
Carolina and Nevada and then of course
you get to Super Tuesday when there's
real money to be spent and she doesn't
have any of it so I think she's in real
trouble and then Joe Biden has shown
once again that he's not a very good
general election or you know Democratic
primary national election candidate and
it does seem that the two people who
have some some some momentum and
traction there are people to judge an
Amy Clovis are and then of course
there's Mike Bloomberg who's gonna be
there with an unlimited amount of money
and campaign budget coming on Super
Tuesday so you know it seems that it's
the the Bernie line and then
there's this middle lane which is a
little crowded with the mayor and
Senator Clovis Shar and Mayor Bloomberg
and a few months ago I really thought
that Warren was gonna be this unity
candidate and she says she still can be
but you're right you you need money yeah
and you know she wasn't campaigning as a
unity candidate cuz she yes she was a
little bit to the right of Bernie
Sanders but she was all for Medicare for
all and you know what it was so
interesting because every candidate gets
their turn in the barrel nobody gets
through a race without having a time
when there's an embarrassment there's
some past statement that comes up and
you see you know the good politicians
for the bad in terms of one how they're
able to power through it
to explain it whether they can keep
their support a lord knows we saw that
with Donald Trump multiple times in 2016
and and you know Elizabeth Warren was at
one point she was the hot candidate into
the summer and early fall but when she
backed off Medicare for all when she was
asked in one of those debates debates
have had a an impact here and I think it
was a Amy Klobuchar who went after her
and said you know you got an idea but
you don't have any way to spend it and
then to pay for it and then in the fall
she came up with her plan and it just
seemed awfully expensive and you know
when she said that there's not going to
even have to raise taxes it's all gonna
come out of taxing for rich people but
the average person who's getting the
Medicare for all is gonna have to pay
for it she sank like a rock and she just
has not recovered well Joe Biden makes a
point as have others that maybe it's
time to talk about Iowa New Hampshire
losing this the stranglehold on the
beginning of the process or too small
they're too white they're not
representative of the country or the
party now like for example a South
Carolina had gone first we might be
talking about Joe Biden mourning away
with this yeah I mean that's an
interesting sort of political science
point we can talk about it in 2021 and -
and what the Democrats are gonna do in
the 2024 cycle but it's too late for him
to make that point now I mean if he had
done that and at one point they were
talking about doing that basically
ignoring the first two states and
focusing on Nevada and South Carolina
which
in the next two weeks and obviously have
a lot more minorities maybe he could
have sold it but the problem was that
that late last summer his own people
went to him and said you can't lose and
do terribly you're the front-runner
you're you're the guy who's and leading
the whole field nationally by 10 points
or more and you can't just ignore Iowa
and New Hampshire and all the buzz and
all the the momentum that will go so he
he went all in and he spent a lot of
money and a lot of time particularly in
Iowa remember he had that one week bus
tour the no malarkey boss I thought that
was an odd choice the no malarkey bus I
mean you know you know 1930s and there
you were there a lot of kids these days
saying malarkey yeah and that's right so
so you know he he didn't have the
courage to make that argument or to live
by that argument and and just ignore the
states and so he got involved and if
you're gonna get involved and try and
you lose and and and and when your whole
argument is electability that I've got
you know that I can win I'm the only one
that can beat Donald Trump but you can't
beat the other Democrats in Iowa and you
can't beat them in in New Hampshire
electability kind of goes out the window
so Nevada is in a week and a half then
South Carolina a week after that and
then Super Tuesday where Michael
Bloomberg's putting a lot of fabric a
eggs into those states now anecdotally I
hear a lot of Democrats saying by the
election I don't care I don't care about
stop and frisk I don't care about any of
it I don't care if he was a Republican
just beat Trump and that seems to be
Bloomberg's argument well it is I mean
he's he's taken some real heat now
because he was a mayor for three terms
12 years and you know like I guess like
a lot of billionaires he was kind of
imperious so instead of like defending
stop and frisk he said you know we need
to take these young african-americans
and throw them up against a wall and
he's talking about redlining now which
is the tank process you know process a
procedure of just redlining maps and
saying we're not going to loan
lend money in these in these poor
african-american neighborhoods and
saying that was really the cause of the
whole housing crisis it wasn't it played
a role but you know he's gonna have to
live with his past statements and some
of his past record and there's a limit
to how much you can apologize but the
main point on I'm agreeing with you on
this Chris is that I think in a normal
race if it were just you know 2016 and
the Democrats were running and the
Republicans were running he'd be sunk by
that but they're the the Animus in the
Democratic Party for Donald Trump in our
exit polls 75% they were asked well how
would you describe your feelings towards
the Trump presidency and 75% said angry
and so a lot of them are gonna hold
their nose and vote for somebody they
wouldn't normally vote for just if they
if they're convinced that Mike Bloomberg
is the is the ticket to getting Donald
Trump out of the White House you see the
tweets back and forth between Bloomberg
also seems like he's more willing to go
on the president's level and I don't
mean that as a hype joke as me in terms
of harshness and the person you know the
personal Nisour the insults well it's
one of the reasons why I think a lot of
political reporters including me would
love to see not that I'm you know
rooting for any particular outcome but a
Trump Bloomberg general election would
be just great to cover because there's
no question that Michael Bloomberg gets
under Donald Trump's skin in a way that
none of these other candidates do
because he you know he attacks him at
his strikes not his weakness I mean he's
the only one who can credibly say I'm a
real billionaire and and you know talk
about Donald and you've got you've got
one billionaire allegedly Donald Trump
who's who is certainly imperious in his
own way and you've got Michael Bloomberg
who's just as imperious and it would it
would be just it would be great to cover
there's no question about it it would be
the best show in town for the final six
months of 2020 and with you last time we
talked there also been no impeachment
yet no that's over
as expected the president has been
completely conciliatory and humbled by
the experience he has he's learned his
lesson it seems to me that neither side
is taking the win here
he instead of just saying look I'm
vindicated I'm moving on he's exacting
revenge I suppose if you want to call it
that and the Democrats could be saying
look we shine the light on the
president's behavior but now instead of
just moving on they're talking about
more and more investigations I couldn't
agree more that I you know I think that
it was an ugly chapter right you can
argue whether or not it was worth doing
for the Democrats you can argue how
strong a weak the case was against the
president but it seems to me that most
people in this country the last thing
they want to do is go down this road
again and we seem to be had it not
necessarily to impeachment but down this
road of the president doing things that
are very questionable I think weighing
in on the sentencing it wasn't a
guideline it was a recommendation by
prosecutors and then the the
recommendation gets changed and now he's
attacking the judge I think that's all
really misguided on his part and and
just you know for those listeners out
there just imagine if it were Barack
Obama doing it to one of his to protect
one of his cronies that you'd they'd be
going out of their minds and conversely
I think for you know and you're hearing
people like Eric's wall well say well
maybe we're going to impeach again
insane just insane
you know I both sides need to focus on
actually helping people deal with the
problems that they do that they face in
this country whether it's the economy or
jobs or education or health care or
foreign policy whatever they need to be
focusing on that and not you know
staying in this kind of politics of
personal destruction and I think both
sides are guilty of it and falling into
the trap again Chris Wallace Fox News
Sunday hos thanks again thank you Chris
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the media buzz
meter with Howard Kurtz how he picks
five stories most important to the most
entertaining to the buzziest
subscribe and listen now by going to Fox
News podcasts calm America is listening
to Fox News now some good news with
Tonya Jay powers major bill White is a
Marine Corps veteran spending 30 years
on active duty and 54 retired he served
in World War two and was awarded a
Purple Heart for surviving the Battle of
Iwo Jima and at 104 one of the ways he
stays busy is scrapbooking this
Valentine's Day he's got a few more
things to put in those books he made a
request of the public for Valentine
cards
I have no reason no personal reasons
it's just a shaving card I guess it was
part of my life the request worked and
he got some okay he got a lot 200,000 of
them he was not expecting that
it just wars me this is know something
has never happened to me before in my
life and I doubt if his road ever happen
again as to what he's going to do with
all those Valentines
well first thing I'll do is I'll get
together with some of the top people who
have been instrumental in by doing what
I'm doing and we'll make a selection of
each part I'm going to have the ideas
and what they wanted to do was would
like to do with them and then we will do
whatever we can and hopefully make
everybody happy he says he saves every
card he's sent and that they become a
personal part of his history Tonya joy
powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Brian Kilmeade what's on your mind the
most intriguing part about this election
season so far has to be the candidacy of
Mike Bloomberg he's already bucked
conventional wisdom he is third on most
national polls on most national averages
yet he did the impossible the
unforgivable
he said goodbye Iowa not interested in
New Hampshire I'm not even gonna compete
in Nevada and I don't care if you put me
in the debates even though he's gonna be
in the debates but he is competing now
so now he is open game and his greatest
asset has there turned into his greatest
albatross and that is his track record
he was tough on crime he cracked down in
high crime areas because in many cases
this that show minorities were located
there and he talked about that and he
was cavalier about that and somewhat
condescending and doing it but the
results were there but the problem is
Mike Bloomberg has already apologized
for what he did in minority communities
and that is bring safety and security
but he did it by cracking down in some
cases on minority so are you following
how Mike Bloomberg is out twisted into a
pretzel he's got to fight his own words
and his own policies that he already
apologized for yet he wants to run on
his record in New York City hey mayor
Mike or mini Mike whatever you go by
these days you can't have it both ways
you can't apologize for low crime at the
same time taking credit for low crime
talking about redlining in districts in
the collapse of the 2000-2008 of the
market and blaming redlining
giving people credit that didn't deserve
it bypass criteria or at all in current
criteria guess what in a lot of those
cases they were minorities you are
trying to win the minority vote to get
the Democratic nomination so how do you
do that Mike
running from your own comments you can't
even say it's how people are
characterizing your comments these are
your comments in your words so far your
crisis management with all your money
and all your billions and all your ads
has been terrible take a day off
don't run an ad for a day or two don't
make a mediocre appearance in front of a
crowd that's mildly interested in you
take a step back and think how do I
defend my record effectively and in a
way that has credibility the president's
going to come after what you did you
could mock them all you
but that's playing his game you have to
act like a billionaire who is self-made
your other problem is your investment in
China and how you don't look at China as
an enemy as a competitor we all know
they're an enemy military and
economically we have evolved to that
point the president effectively showed
us he was a hundred percent right and
it's taken them on the last thing we
need is a step back redlining
stop-and-frisk China three hurdles from
any mic to scale I'm not sure he's up to
it we're all about to find out I'm Brian
Kilmeade make sure you listen to my
radio show wherever you get it Eastern
Time 9:00 to noon wherever you can
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios hourly newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
hello the one one with Greg Gutfeld
Jennifer Harriman my ex-husband Neil
Haggerty like we wrote all the songs
together but then he peeked out and
didn't want anything to do with the
mixing right so you know you're putting
stuff in my lap and you're gonna get a
little bit of my flavors subscribed and
listen now by going to a Fox News
podcasts dot-com